The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Here is the menu for today.
We're discussing line
shifts and line broadening.
And I want to finish
up today this chapter
by describing collisional
narrowing, also called
Dicke narrowing.
Then I want to have
two more shorter topics
on two other aspects which
lead to important line shapes
and line broadening.
So I want to quickly discuss
the spectrum of emitted light
by an atom.
And I want to discuss
collisional broadening.
None of that will
be done in-depth.
The spectrum of emitted
light is really open-ended,
and we will have a more
advanced treatment in 8.422.
But I do feel if I show you
all are kinds of line shifts
and line broadening,
I should at least
mention here the basic things.
And collisional
broadening, I'm not
sure how many atomic
physics courses
you will find which teach
about collision broadening,
because this is the physics
from gas discharge lamps,
the old-fashioned physics.
However, I've realized
that a lot of people
know now about clock shifts,
and mean field broadening,
and mean field, and
the ultra-cold gases.
And they have no idea that
similar physics actually
happens in ordinary gas.
So at least in terms of
broadening your understanding,
I want to talk just 10 minutes
about collisional broadening.
I've completely eliminated
from this course
the quantitative description
about collisional broadening,
but I want to show
you a few cartoons
and put some pictures
into your mind.
And probably, we have time to
start the next chapter, which
is actually a pretty short
one, on two-photon transitions.
For me, actually,
Dicke narrowing
is really the highlight
of the course,
because it provides
conceptual insight
into what really
line broadening is,
and to realize that collisions
can narrow lines and not
just broaden them.
This is sort of
subtle and insightful.
And similar to photon
transitions, it's short,
but I hope it's also a
highlight, because there's
so many people-- you and other
people-- who are sometimes
struggling-- a photon is
absorbed and is emitted.
Usually, the photon
is not absorbed,
the photon is scattered.
And whenever you think
about photon in, photon out,
you really should think
about two-photon transitions.
So the framework of
two-photon transitions
allows me now to give you the
tools how you should really
think about whenever you have
atoms interacting with light.
The light is not absorbed,
the light is just scattered.
And so you need that.
On the other hand, based
on all the descriptions
I've given you about
light-atom interaction,
two-photon
transitions would just
mean we need one more order
of perturbation theory,
and then it's the same thing
you have already learned.
So it's a highlight, and it's
to some extent also a review.
You will actually recognize, in
some situations, the difference
between two-photon processes
and one-photon processes.
It's not so big, it's just
you have to-- you'll see.
You have to use a
different Rabi frequency
and some different concepts.
OK.
So that's, I think, really
an agenda of highlights.
Let's go back to the physical
picture we drew up on Wednesday
about Dicke narrowing.
I just explained
to you that when
we have an atom which is
trapped and tightly confined,
that the spectrum consists of
a sharp light and sidebands.
And now I was addressing
the situation--
what happens if you
have an atom which
is surrounded by buffer gas?
I would say, well, that's a
cheap trap created by nature,
because when the particle
wants to fly away,
it collides with
a buffer gas atom.
So it stays put.
So it's a cheap trap, but
it's also a lousy trap,
because there is some randomness
in the number of collisions.
But I'm waving my
arm, so that maybe you
can go along with the picture
that it is an ensemble of traps
which have very different
trap frequencies.
And then we would expect,
based on our understanding
of the spectrum of
confined particles,
that we have a carrier,
which is always the same,
at the electronic
excitation frequency.
But then we have sidebands
at the trap frequency.
But those sidebands
are now smeared out,
because we do not have a
defined harmonic oscillator
potential here.
So therefore, I sort of
tried to lead you in the way
that that may be one way how you
can think about the situation.
And well, now I want to give you
a different way to look at it.
And let's see how those
things come together.
So if I would ask you, give
me a quantitative estimate
how wide this line
is, do you have
any idea how we can do that?
Or let me even put it this way.
It's again one of
those kind of things--
you have the knowledge, but
to put it together is hard.
But I would guarantee
everybody in this room
has the knowledge to write
down in one line what
is the width of this line.
What is the width of this line?
It's an inverse time.
What time?
Coherence time.
Yeah.
But now, if you have an
atom which is now starting
and it hits buffer
gas, how would you
estimate the coherence time?
AUDIENCE: Mean free pass.
PROFESSOR: Mean free
pass will be important.
But the coherence
time-- how long
will the atom talk to the laser
beam in a phase-coherent way?
So what do we have to
compare to the wavelengths?
AUDIENCE: Mean free pass.
PROFESSOR: The mean free pass.
This will be the
important parameter.
But if the mean free
pass is much shorter
than the wavelengths?
Well, the atom has just
moved a tiny bit, one mean.
Is it still coherent
at this time?
AUDIENCE: It's
shorter than the wave.
PROFESSOR: If the mean free
path is shorter than the wave.
So it will do many collisions.
But since it stays localized, it
will still coherently interact.
When will it stop
coherently interacting?
AUDIENCE: Mean free path.
PROFESSOR: No, the mean
free path is always smaller.
Let's just assume that.
I hear "diffusion."
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
The atom has a short
mean free path,
but it will do a random walk.
And the movement it diffuses
by more than a wavelength,
it has randomly changed its
position by a wavelength.
And that would
mean it experiences
the phase of the drive
field in a random way.
End of coherence.
1 over this time
is its line width.
OK.
So let me write that down.
So based on the
concepts we have learned
by looking at Doppler
broadening and all that,
we realize the
important aspect is,
when do atoms in an ensemble
randomly move by a wavelength?
So therefore, our
estimate is now--
estimate the widths
of the sharp peak.
We use a model
which is diffusion.
We know that in diffusion,
the random walk, the RMS
position in atom has moved away.
Ballistic motion
is linear in time.
Diffusive motion is the
square root of time,
or z square is linear in time.
And we have the
diffusion constant.
Diffusion by, well,
lambda or lambda
bar after time, which
is wavelength squared.
So therefore, we would
expect that the full width
at 1/2 maximum of our peak
is k squared-- k, the wave
vector of the light, and D
is the diffusion constant.
Well, since you mentioned
the mean free path, let me,
already at this point-- I
wanted to do it earlier,
but it fits in very well here.
In an ideal gas, the
diffusion constant
is given by some thermal average
speed times the mean free path.
And if you look
up some textbooks,
there's a factor of 3.
So our delta omega,
which is k squared
D. Let me write it
as k times v bar.
And the other k I write
as 1 over lambda bar.
So this is k squared,
and I need l.
So this is nothing
else than k squared--
I take this expression,
k squared l.
This is one k, this
is the other k.
And v bar times l is
the ideal gas expression
for the diffusion constant.
But now you realize that k, dot,
v-- since in a gas, the most
probably velocity is
also the momentum spread,
this is nothing else
than the Doppler width.
So therefore, we find
that the line widths
in Dicke narrowing--
if we have buffer gas
and we have diffusive
motion-- is much smaller--
and this is why it's
called Dicke narrowing--
than the Doppler broadening
if the mean free path is
much smaller than
the wavelength.
So this is where the
mean free path comes in.
What happens if
the mean free path
is much longer than
the wavelength?
What line widths do we then get?
Do we then have a
line width which
is larger than the
Doppler broadening,
or do we get the
Doppler broadening?
Let's have a clicker question.
So if l is much smaller
than lambda bar,
is delta omega-- and this
is your option A-- equal to?
Or option B, larger?
OK.
So what do you think?
It's always a question
when we derive something,
how seriously you should
take what we derived.
So this expression
for delta omega Dicke
shows that the line width
would get larger and larger
the longer the
mean free path is.
And the question is,
is that correct or not?
OK.
Any more takers?
Whoops.
Oops.
Sorry, press again.
I erased it by clicking
the wrong button.
You've already
made up your mind.
You know the answer.
So stop, display.
Yes.
The majority answer
is definitely correct.
What happens until the
first collision happens,
you just have
normal Doppler-- you
don't have diffusive motion,
you have ballistic motion.
And if the line width is already
determined once the atoms have
spread out by a wavelength,
that's it already.
And then if then the particles
collide, it doesn't matter.
So what we have assumed
is we've assumed
that the relevant model for
the spread out to a wavelength
is a diffusive model.
And if we are past that--
because the mean free path is
larger than the
wavelength-- we have
to go back to normal
Doppler broadening.
OK.
But now let me calculate
Dicke narrowing
by using the formalism
we have developed.
So let's use the correlation
function for that.
And we know that the line
width was nothing else
than the Fourier transform
of the correlation function,
how the atoms
experience the drive
field at two different times.
So we had here the
matrix element,
the Rabi frequency squared.
We have between time
t and t plus tau,
the phase of the drive
field accumulates
e to the i omega tau.
But now we have the e
to the minus ikr factor.
And r, or the position--
in diffusion, you
often call it s-- changes now,
because the particle undergoes
a random walk.
So what we have to do is to
describe collisional narrowing,
we have to take this
factor and average it
over our ensemble of
diffusing particles.
And well, diffusion means that
if particles start out at t
equals 0 at the
origin, the probability
that we find the
particle at time t,
a distance s away
from the origin--
so I'm depicting this one here.
The particle does
sort of a random walk.
And after time t, it
is out at a position s.
And the probability for
that is e to the minus
s squared over 4 Dt.
And you see it's s
is quadratic over t.
This is a random walk. s
increases s's square root
of time.
And the probability is
normalized by this expression.
So therefore, this red average
in the correlation function
is calculated by convoluting
with this probability
distribution for
the random walk.
So it is e to the minus
iks, e to the minus
s squared over 4 D. The
time is now called tau.
We used to integrate
over all possibilities.
And e to the i omega
tau is a common factor.
My notes show that the integral
is done from minus infinity
to plus infinity.
Either this is right, or
there's a factor of two
to be accounted, because
well, it depends.
Now, is s a coordinate,
or is s in radians?
In one case, it has a sign,
in the other case, it has not.
I'm not able to
reconstruct it now,
but it's just a
numerical factor,
which would be affected by that.
So the result of
this integral is
that we obtain an
exponential function.
So what we find out
is that there is now
an exponentially
decaying function.
Remember, we had situations
where the correlation function
for how the atom
experiences a coherent field
was decaying
exponentially because
of spontaneous lifetime?
And now we have an
exponential decay,
because the particle
is defusing around.
But we also know, of course,
that exponential decay, when
we Fourier analyze it,
gives us a Lorentzian.
So when we ask what is the
rate, Fermi's golden rule's
rate expression, the
rate for excitation.
We want to do the Fourier
transform of this correlation
function.
And what we obtain is, well,
a Lorentzian which looks
like the Lorentzian for
spontaneous emission,
except for that we have
a different width now.
It's a Lorentzian with a
width 2 k squared times D.
So pretty straightforward.
But I hope you've
seen and you've
enjoyed there's a very
intuitive picture.
But the correlation
function-- if you just
look at it from the
perspective of the atoms,
how do I experience
a coherent field?
You put in simply
the diffusive motion.
You can exactly calculate
what the line shape is.
And that's definitely
something you would not
have known how to do it
without this formalism.
OK.
I have a question for you.
And this is, how does the
spectrum for diffusive motion
look like?
What we have just
calculated was that it
is a Lorentzian with the line
widths we've just determined.
But I want to give
you another choice.
And this is what we discussed
at the end of the last class.
This picture where we took
the confined particles
to the ridiculous limit-- where
there was no trap anymore,
just collisions--
suggested actually
that we have some sharp line.
But then this envelope
of those sidebands
give some unresolved pedestal.
So the question is,
what is correct?
We have just done a
quantitative calculation
using the model, a
diffusion propagator.
But we also had this
intuitive picture,
which had more this kind
of bimodal distribution.
A broad pedestal
and a sharp peak.
And I want you to think
about it for a few seconds.
What would you expect to
be the correct answer?
Is the line shape
just a Lorentzian,
or does the line shape have
two different parts to it?
OK.
Does somebody want to speak out
in favor of his or her choice?
Well, one argument is,
when you derive something,
it must be more correct than
when you wave your hands.
Therefore, we
derived a Lorentzian,
and the other picture
was just waving our hands
and using some analogy.
OK.
That would be one
argument to vote
for A. Somebody
wants to defend B?
Pardon?
AUDIENCE: More intuitive.
PROFESSOR: More intuitive.
Yes.
You know, something
must be right about it.
I mean, in some limit,
this must be like a trap,
and there should
be some sidebands.
Yes.
OK.
But now I would ask you-- Nancy,
if you say it's more intuitive,
why don't we get
those broadening?
Why don't we get
this extra pedestal
in our quantitative derivation?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: But what?
Didn't we lose the exact
probability distribution
for diffusive process?
AUDIENCE: There's no
harmonic oscillator.
The sidebands [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So that's
an argument also for A.
We don't have a
harmonic oscillator.
And when I said there is sort
of this trap-type feature,
I'm really over-extending
the analogy.
AUDIENCE: The mean
free path is not--
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: The mean free path
is not infinitesimally small.
PROFESSOR: The mean free path
Now we're getting close.
We assumed diffusive motion.
We put in the exact expression
for diffusive motion.
And of course, you also know,
when you describe a line width,
what happens in the
middle at detuning
0 is more what happens in
the limit of long times.
What happens further and further
out happens at shorter times.
What is the motion of
atoms at short times?
Before the first collision
happens, it moves straight.
So the diffusive
propagator which we put in
is only valid after
the first collision.
Until the first collision
happens, we have free motion.
And free motion should give rise
to simple Doppler broadening.
So until the first
collision happens,
we should get a little
bit of Doppler broadening.
But once the
collisions happened,
we should be very well
within the description
of the diffusion operator.
And to address your
concern, actually,
in the limit of many
sideband, often,
the envelope of
all those sidebands
is actually determined
by the Doppler profile.
There is a limit, if you have
a large modulation index,
that you have many sidebands.
And in some
semi-classical limit,
the sidebands have an envelope
which is the Doppler profile.
So now I think the
two pictures agree.
If we had used a propagator
which would interpolate
between the first moment where
the particle moves straight,
and then diffusion, we would
have gotten little pedestals
here.
And so that sort of tells us
that the smeared outside bands,
yes, strictly speaking, they
are linked to harmonic motion.
But they are sort
of the leftover
of the motional effect,
which is the Doppler effect.
OK.
Good.
So we have the
correct answer here.
And here, it is the model
neglects ballistic motion
until the first collision.
Questions?
OK.
Let's now spend 10
minutes discussing
the fluorescent
spectrum of an atom.
As I pointed out in my overview,
we teach much more about it
in 8.422.
We use a dressed atom picture.
But something would be missing
if I wouldn't do it also
in this course, because
we have discussed
to quite some extent what
happens when we excite atoms
with light.
And what we have
discussed so far
is that we excite atom and scan
the laser, or the excitation
frequency.
And when we are plotting the
intensity of the fluorescence,
we are looking at the
number of scattered photon.
And what we are scanning is
the detuning of the laser.
We would expect, in the case
of a motionless atom, simply
a Lorentzian, or in
the general limit,
a power-broadened Lorentzian.
Just to be clear, what I'm
discussing in those 10 minutes
is I'm completely ignoring
that the atom can move.
So you should think
that it's either
an atom with infinite mass,
or it's an atom tightly
localized in the
Lamb-Dicke limit,
and all we are looking at is the
structure of the central peak.
So no motional effects.
We just look at the pure
kind of intrinsic line
widths of the
electronic transition.
OK.
So we have discussed that.
But now I want to look at
another aspect of spectroscopy.
And this is another
scan we can do.
We want to have
a fixed detuning.
And we look at the spectrum
of the emitted light.
So let's assume that
we have a laser which
is at a detuning delta.
The laser is fixed.
The light is emitting.
But we are now dispersing
with a spectrograph.
We are analyzing what is the
frequency of the emitted light.
And we determine the spectrum.
And yes, the question is,
how does it look like?
And I want to give
you four options.
So this is 0 detuning
at resonance.
Oops, I need one more.
Let me relabel it
to make it clear.
So our option one
is our spectrum
is a delta function at
the resonance of the atom.
Option two is it is a Lorentzian
centered around the resonance.
Option three is it is a
delta function at the laser
frequency.
And option four is it is a
Lorentzian with line width
gamma.
So we have two options.
Is it a delta function
at omega 0 or omega l?
Or is it a Lorentzian-broadened
function at either omega 0
or omega l.
And since we want to
keep things simple,
we want to first discuss the
case of the perturbative case
that the laser which excites
the atom has very low power.
So what would you expect?
An atom is excited, it's
a little light bulb.
You analyze the spectrum
of the light bulb.
Which of the four
spectrum will you measure?
OK.
Let's try again.
[LAUGHTER]
And maybe I should, like
our online learning system,
try to give you one hint.
I want you to really think hard
what energy conservation means
in this problem.
OK.
OK, we're getting closer.
Now, the way how I want
you to think about it
is if you take the
limit of low power,
you should really think
about it that there
is only one photon in
your whole laboratory.
This photon is
scattered of an atom,
and then you measure the
frequency of the photon.
And energy conservation clearly
tells us that the frequency
of the scattered photon cannot
be at the resonance frequency.
It has to be at the
laser frequency.
Otherwise, we would
violate energy.
But it seems-- still,
the more subtle thing
is, is it a delta function?
Of course, a delta
function will be broadened.
If you do the experiment
for one second,
you will have a Fourier
line width which is 1 hertz.
But that's, for
practical reasons, almost
like a delta function, because
the spectral line widths,
or the natural line widths
of your favorite atom
is 10 megahertz.
So there will be some
temporal broadening,
which is in case in any
realistic experiment.
But we are talking about, are
you limited by the experiment
and by technical
noise, or are you
limited by the
natural line widths?
Now, I would argue, just
with energy conservation--
but I'll give you another
argument in a second--
that if I have a
monochromatic laser,
the photon which
has to come out has
to be exactly the
same frequency.
Because we talked about
energy conservation.
And if I would start with a
photon at the laser frequency
and I would measure a photon
which has 10 megahertz away,
I would violate energy
conservation by 10 megahertz.
So the argument is
actually correct.
It's a delta function
at the drive frequency.
But I want to give
you another argument.
It's, again, something you
have heard in the course.
But you should really
take it seriously,
and apply to that situation.
And that's the following.
Remember when we talked
about the AC stark effect.
I told you that
you should really
think about the atom as
a harmonic oscillator.
We even introduced for you
the oscillator strengths
that we could even
quantitatively describe
the response of the atom
to the scattering of light
by pretty much a model where we
have a mechanical model where
an electron is attached
with a spring to an origin.
OK.
Let me now paraphrase
the question.
Well, I've given you the answer.
Before giving you
the answer, I should
have asked you the
following-- if you now
make the assumption that you
have a harmonic oscillator,
the harmonic oscillator has a
resonance frequency of omega 0.
And it has a damping
rate of gamma.
But we are driving the harmonic
oscillator not at omega 0;
we were driving it at
a frequency omega l.
At what frequency does the
harmonic oscillator respond?
At the drive frequency
or at its own frequency?
AUDIENCE: Drive.
PROFESSOR: Of course.
It's a drive frequency.
And if you have a CW experiment,
I said let's wait a second,
let's really do a
long experiment,
if you have a driven
harmonic oscillator,
and you drive it
for a long time,
and you analyze the
spectrum of the motion,
is the frequency spectrum of
the driven harmonic oscillator
absolutely sharp at
the drive frequency?
Or is it broadened by
gamma, the damping constant
of the harmonic oscillator?
AUDIENCE: Sharp.
PROFESSOR: Who
thinks it's sharp?
Who thinks it's broad?
Hands up for sharp.
Hands up for broad.
OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Look, what you are
overlooking is the following.
There is the difference
between a transient, which
is damped out at a rate gamma.
But then there is
the CW response.
If you have an ultra-weak drive,
you leave it on for an hour,
the harmonic oscillator
will reach steady state.
And it will just oscillate
driven by your drive.
And it's actually monochromatic.
And if you analyze
the motion, it's
a harmonic oscillator in
steady state with a drive,
and it just moves with a fixed
amplitude and fixed frequency.
I mean, the way how
I shake my hands,
this is a delta function
at the drive frequency.
So in this simple
harmonic oscillator model,
gamma and damping
comes in when you
do what I discussed
earlier, when
you change the drive frequency.
But this is a completely
different experiment.
We are not changing
the drive frequency
and looking for the response.
We are a fixed drive
frequency, and we
are analyzing what the
motion is which comes out.
And then, as you know from
differential equation,
you may have a grade transient.
You may have a transient
at the resonance frequency
which dies out
with a rate gamma.
This is when you suddenly
switch on your drive,
and you're not adiabatically
switching on your drive.
But this is just a transient.
But what we are asking here
when you do a CW experiment,
you drive it for a long
time, you look what happens.
And the motion of the
driven harmonic oscillator
is a delta function
at the drive.
And what is valid for
a harmonic oscillator
is also valid for
the atom, pretty much
for the same reasons.
Any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Regarding the
energy conservation in D,
wouldn't the photon processes
explain energy conservation?
PROFESSOR: OK.
You are now really
asking-- Nancy
is asking about
two-photon processes.
Well, we don't
want to stop here.
We want to see something
more interesting.
This is just sort of the
trivial, simple harmonic
oscillator.
The question is now, if you
want to see something richer,
if we want to see a
little bit of broadening,
or we want to see something
which is not as boring as just
a classical harmonic oscillator,
what do we have to do?
AUDIENCE: Increase the strength.
PROFESSOR: Increase the
strengths of the field.
And I heard somebody
saying, two photons.
And that may be--
AUDIENCE: Next-order
perturbation theory.
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: It's like next
order perturbation theory.
PROFESSOR: Next-order
perturbation theory.
But just in the sort
of intuitive picture,
if you have two photons
which come quickly enough--
and how quickly the two
photons come will be debated.
Of course, it's parametrized
by the Rabi frequency,
the strengths of the drive.
But if two photons come
quickly, each photon
has to be scattered with
a delta function because
of energy conservation.
But if we have two
photons, suddenly, it's
possible that one is scattered
here and one is scattered here.
And we still conserve energy.
So if you want to see some form
of line broadening, if you want
to see all the things
you have mentioned,
we have to go away from
the low power limit.
And this is what we do next.
So we assume that we
have higher power.
We are on resonance.
And let me assume that the Rabi
frequency is larger than gamma.
So what is the physics now
of the atom if the Rabi
frequency is larger than gamma?
It can do Rabi oscillation
before it's damped.
So now we have a
system which has
an internal dynamics
at the Rabi frequency.
And you know if you
have an emitter,
if you have an antenna
which emits light,
and you move the antenna
around at a frequency--
we had the example of a trapped
particle which has a trapped
frequency of omega
trap-- the spectrum,
if you Fourier transform, it
leads to the basal function,
it leads to the sideband.
So therefore, we know now,
based on all the analogies,
if you have a modulated
emitter, we obtain sidebands.
That's what we would
expect classically.
So let me now ask you the
three following possibilities.
Maybe we still get
a delta function.
Maybe we get three peaks where
the splitting is the Rabi
frequency.
So the two outer
peaks have a-- and the
third option is that yes, we
observe the Rabi frequency,
but the Rabi frequency
is the splitting
between the outer peaks.
So the first and second
answer differ by a factor of 2
in the sideband spacing.
So we have three choices.
Do we expect sidebands?
That's A and B. Or would
you expect that we still
have a delta function,
because, well, maybe energy has
to be conserved at the
single photon level?
And then is the splitting
Rabi frequency on each side,
or Rabi frequency between
the two sidebands?
All right.
Yes.
It's indeed the situation.
For those who picked
A, it's pretty much
the definition of what
the Rabi frequency is.
After one cycle of
the Rabi frequency,
the atom has gone
from the ground state
to the excited state and
back to the ground state.
So the model you should have is
that you have an object which
is emitting light,
but the object
has some internal modulation
at the Rabi frequency.
Whatever factor of 2
you had in the amplitude
versus probability or
something, all this
has been factored into
the definition of the Rabi
frequency in such a way
the atom is really blinking
between ground and excited
state with a frequency
which is the Rabi frequency.
And this frequency
leads-- and the spectrum
is now the sum and difference
of the relevant frequencies.
And the relevant frequency
is the resonance frequency
and the Rabi frequency.
So the answer is B.
But this was sort of more
in form of a stick diagram.
Now I want to bring in
in the next question
the line broadening.
So the question is-- and
there are again four choices.
The question is, we have
now our three sticks.
One is a carrier, and these
are the two sidebands split off
by a Rabi frequency.
Are all three sticks now
sharp delta functions?
Are all three sticks broadened
by the natural line widths?
Is the central part
sharp, and only the
sidebands are broadened?
Or do we have a sharp
stick with a pedestal,
and then two sidebands?
I'm not actually expecting
all of you to know the answer,
because this is
really now getting
into more subtle things.
But just in terms
of show-and-tell,
and attract your curiosity
to the second part
of the course, what
would you expect?
OK.
Yes.
Good.
A is definitely eliminated.
I mean, if we scatter two
photons simultaneously, there
will be sort of
broadening of gamma,
because the atom has
a natural broadening.
So we can't expect that the
two photon processes are sharp.
There's no reason
to expect that.
The answer between B,
C, and D depends now.
If we have very, very little
power, what we observe
is, of course, the
low-power delta function.
And then we observe very,
very small sidebands
which are broadened.
So answer C is correct.
If you just think
about it-- what
is the structure of
infinitesimal peaks?
But when you crank up the
power, and what you have is
you have an elastic
scattering peak,
which has a delta function,
energy conservation
at the single photon level.
And then you have those-- they
are called inelastic peaks.
But when you crank up the
power, then the central feature
has also an inelastic component.
You can sort of argue
that in Rabi oscillation,
you are in the ground state,
excited state, ground state,
excited state.
But if you do now light
scattering in the excited
state, you
automatically broaden it
by the lifetime of
the excited state.
And if you crank up the
power higher and higher,
the elastic peak will be
more and more suppressed.
And you find actually
a spectrum which
has only three broadened
peaks, and the delta function
has disappeared.
It will actually be something
where we need more knowledge.
The broadening of those
peaks is not gamma anymore.
One of them will be 3/2
gamma, the other one
will be 1/2 gamma.
But this now really requires
a deeper understanding
in terms of the atom picture.
But the scale of
all the broadening
is a factor on the order
of unity times gamma.
Any questions?
So the general answer, sorry,
would be-- the generic picture
which you should keep
in your mind is that.
You have inelastic scattering
on all three peaks.
But the limit of D at
very low power is that.
And at very high power, is that.
The elastic component
of the central peak
is either 100% or 0%.
OK.
So our last topic for line
shapes and line broadening
is pressure broadening.
And as I mentioned
in the introduction,
pressure broadening has
made modern appearances
in the form of clock shift,
and mean field shifts,
and mean field broadenings
in Bose-Einstein condensates.
But let me sort of
tell you how you
should understand
pressure broadening.
I'm using here the
semi-classical picture
that an excited atom
acts as an oscillator.
And what happened is the atom--
you can say the oscillation
is superposition of
ground and excited state.
It oscillates.
But after some time tau, there
may be a quenching collision,
a de-excitation collision.
Then the atom is sort
of in the ground state.
And then it waits until it's
excited again by the laser,
and the atomic dipole
is oscillating again.
In a situation like
this, you would
expect that the total
line widths is actually
the sum of two rates.
One is the spontaneous
emission rate,
and the other one would be the
collision rate, which is this.
And in general, this is sort
of how people looked at it.
You vary the pressure
in your buffer gas cell,
and you find that the line
width has a component which
increases linearly
with pressure.
So this is one model
how you can imagine
what happens in a collision.
These are like
knock-out collisions.
When an atom collides,
the excitation, the energy
disappears.
The atom is quenched
to the ground state.
Well, we can draw
up another model,
where we have an oscillation
of our atomic oscillator.
But then after
the same time tau,
there is now a
hiccup in the phase.
It collides with another atom.
The other atom is
not de-exciting.
It's not removing the energy.
But after the
collision, the atom
continues to oscillate, but with
a very, very different phase.
And sort of what I assumed
here is this time where
the collision happens
is very short.
It's a very short
collision time.
That I can approximate
the collisions
as simply imparting random
phase jumps to the atom.
Well, if you ask,
what is the widths
of the spectroscopic line,
it's exactly the same result.
It just means we have
a different rate.
It's now a de-phasing
rate, which is 1 over tau.
And this is added to the
spectroscopic widths.
OK.
This is sort of just creating
some phenomenological picture.
Let's now ask a little
bit more microscopically.
How can it happen?
How can it happen that there
is a phase change, that there's
a change in the phase of
the atomic oscillator?
And this leads us now to
consider the interaction
potential as a function
of r between two atoms.
We have one atom which is
sort of our active atom, which
has an excited and ground state.
And this atom is now
getting closer to,
let's say, an argon atom,
which acts as buffer gas.
And what I'm plotting
in this graph now
is the interaction potential
between our light-emitting,
or light-absorbing, atoms
and the buffer gas atom.
And let's just
genetically assume there
is sort of something like
a molecular potential.
But in general, the
molecular potentials
will be different in the
ground and excited state.
And of course, if you
do hyperfine transitions
between atoms in a
Bose-Einstein condensate,
you may have a
scattering length,
which is different
in the two states.
And I think you
see the connection.
So in general, if the
interaction environment
is different between
ground and excited state,
we expect that the
interaction potential
causes certain shifts.
So we could use the picture
that we have a phase evolution.
And the phase evolution
is a frequency difference
which is simply given by
the difference of the two
potentials.
So the picture is a little
bit-- which is actually
very valid for cold
collisions, which-- well,
really a new chapter
in atomic physics
opened up by laser cooling
and magneto-optic traps.
An atom, when it emits a
photon, would emit here
at the resonance frequency.
But if the collision
is very, very slow,
it will actually emit,
with a certain probability,
a photon which is shifted
by exactly this expression.
And in that limit, that
could be very interesting,
because by analyzing
the spectrum
of the immediate light,
you learn something
about the interaction
potential of two atoms.
But of course, this argument
has a little bit of a flaw,
because you can observe a
frequency not instantaneously.
You can observe-- if a
collision happens very fast,
you would actually go through
those frequency changes so fast
that you cannot resolve them.
The question is,
which one is larger?
So if the frequency
shift is larger
than the inverse time for the
duration of the collision,
then you can observe it.
Otherwise, you can't.
So the picture we should
draw is now the following.
And this is sort of
a microscopic picture
on those phase jumps,
which I mentioned earlier.
That you have your
atomic oscillator.
The atom is oscillating.
But now it comes
close to another atom.
And let's assume there
is an energy increase
between ground and excited
state due to the presence
of the buffer gas atom.
Then you would say you
get a quick oscillation.
Depending on the
impact parameter,
it can last various
amount of time.
And then later, the
oscillation starts.
But essentially, this
causes a random phase jump.
So this time here is the
collision time tau c.
What we expect now is we
have to now interpolate
between two models.
I'm not taking it any
further than that.
We have an interesting
line shape.
There may be a central part
which is simply collisionally
broadened by the
interruptions of the phase,
by the number of collisions
with the collision time tau.
But if when the atoms collide,
there is a huge frequency shift
momentarily, that this will
actually affect the wings.
So for frequency shifts which
come from the interaction
potential which are much
larger than the collision time,
than the time
between collisions,
we will observe
something which goes
by the name "far
wing broadening."
And also, the central part
of the potential is simply,
you can say, it's a
Lorentzian which is simply
broadened by the collision rate.
There is no microscopic
information--
what is the nature,
what is going on
during the phase jumps.
The wings will have
actually information
about the molecular potential.
And I just wanted to present
it to you in this way
to sort of show how you
actually have, in a line shape,
often two effects.
One is pretty much
just the interruption
of the coherence which
gives the central line.
But you still have, at
least in some limit,
information about what
causes those phase jumps.
And this appears in the wings.
20 years ago in the
atomic physics course,
we taught you a theory
how to describe that.
It could be probably
taught in one hour.
There are some
links on the Wiki,
but I don't want to
carry that further.
Any questions about that?
AUDIENCE: So why has the
importance decreased?
PROFESSOR: The
importance has decreased
of that, because
I mean, who of you
is studying atoms and gas cells?
Nobody.
The frontier has moved on.
We are much more in a
regime where we are not
observing atoms in
certain environment.
We are creating an interesting
system out of atoms
by putting the atoms in a
well-defined environment where
those things are absent.
Or in the ultra-cold
domain, and de Broglie
wavelengths is so long that this
kind of model for collisions
is no longer applicable.
We are in the extreme case of
a single partial wave, where
a single parameter,
the scattering lengths,
describes all of it.
OK.
Cory?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Could you talk for a
little bit about how
this model of collisions
breaks down and allows
for Dicke narrowing?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Thank you.
That was one comment I forgot.
What happens is you have Dicke--
thanks for this question.
You have Dicke-- I drew up
the two potential curves.
If the two potential curves
are absolutely identical,
the atoms can approach
each other and can collide.
But there is never
any perturbation
to the atomic oscillator,
because the frequency
between ground and
excited state is omega 0,
no matter whether the atom
undergoes a collision or not.
In this limit, which is
often realized in collisions
with rare gases,
in this limit, you
do not have any phase
interruption by the collision.
And this is the prerequisite
for Dicke narrowing.
OK.
I think we have the
full picture now.
And that means we can move
on to two-photon excitations.
So whenever you
start a new chapter,
you should motivate it.
And the question is, why
should you be interested?
Well, I can also turn it
around and said, why not?
Because those things happen.
And if those things happen,
we want to learn about them.
And they actually
happen very naturally.
The moment you go to
higher laser power
and you go beyond the lowest
order of perturbation theory,
you may actually excite two
photons at the same time.
And actually, what we just
discussed about the emission
spectrum of an atom, with the
sidebands, with the broadening,
these are actually
examples where we really
have to think about it in
a two-photon picture, not
a single-photon picture.
The second motivation
is very practical.
We may want to excite an
atom from a low-lying level
to a high-lying level.
But the only laser we can
buy, or the only laser we have
in the laboratory
has lower frequency.
That doesn't mean
that the case is
lost by just stacking two
photons on top of each other.
We can bridge the
gap and still excite
the atom, which has
transitions only far in the UV.
And all we have is
these visible lasers.
There's another
thing which changes.
Maybe we want to excite hydrogen
from the 1s to the 2s level.
1s and 2s have the same parity.
And if we try to excite
it with one photon,
because of the dipole
operator which has odd parity,
this is not allowed.
So there are maybe
selection rules
where we can go to
desirable final state
only with two photons
and not with one photon.
Finally, I will show you
on Wednesday-- remember,
there is no class on Monday,
because the whole CUA
will go crazy with the NSF
site visit on Monday, Tuesday.
So the next class on Wednesday.
And on Wednesday,
I will actually
show you if the two photons come
from counter-propagating beams,
the net momentum transfer
to the atom is 0.
And net momentum transfer of
0 means zero Doppler shift.
So two photons give
us an opportunity,
which doesn't exist
with the single photon.
We can excite the atom
without transferring momentum.
And this is the basis of a
Doppler free spectroscopy
technique.
And finally, for purely
conceptional reasons,
we've talked so much about
excitation of an atom,
and then ask, what is the
rate of light scattering?
So we have actually used
two-photon processes
in the course many, many
times without actually
adequately addressing them.
I didn't tell you
anything wrong.
I was sort of choosing
my words carefully,
that everything I told you about
light emission and absorption
is comparable with
the correct picture.
And the correct picture
is if a photon goes in
and a photon goes out,
you have to describe it
as one process
involving two photons.
So I think we have
enough reasons why
we should be interested.
And if I take this picture,
that I start in one state
and have a two-photon
absorption process,
I actually want to
redraw it, because
in the dipole approximation,
which I want to use here,
we have the dipole operator,
and second quantization
is a plus a dagger.
The electric field
So each application
of the operator
takes us from one state to
the next with a single photon.
So therefore, if you
talk about two photons,
we can only absorb
them if we have
an intermediate state,
which I will call f.
So we should really think
about two-photon absorption
as a two-step process which
involves an intermediate state.
And it has to be
like that if we want
to use, as the
operator for atom light
interaction, the
dipole operator,
because a dipole
operator is creating
and-- the dipole operator
involves electric field.
And that creates or annihilates
one photon at a time.
Let me just make a
side remark, but this
will be addressed in 8.422.
If you use the description
of the interaction
with the electromagnetic
field, which
is the p minus e Hamiltonian,
and you square it,
if you square that, you
get an A squared term.
The A squared term is
actually the product
of a plus a dagger squared.
So you can actually,
with the A squared term,
scatter two photons by going
from one state to another one.
But I'm not discussing it here.
And I leave a detailed
comparison and discussion
of that to 8.422.
Now we are strictly adhering
to the dipole approximation.
Oh, actually, let me
make a comment about it,
because I just realized if I
say something and don't say it
fully, I may confuse people.
So what I want to say is,
we will show, in 8.422
that the two pictures, the
pap minus a Hamiltonian
and the dipole Hamiltonian
are equivalent.
They're connected by
canonical transformation.
So therefore, it is not a
fundamental aspect of nature,
whether you can scatter
only one photon when
you go from one
state to the other.
There are two
equivalent descriptions.
In one description, you
sometimes scatter two photons.
In the other description,
you scatter only one photon.
And you will all
get a PSET in 8.422
where you show for one
example that the results are
the same when you sum up
over all possibilities.
So therefore, I can
maybe here should rather
take the position, the generic
description of light scattering
uses the dipole approximation.
And in the dipole
approximation, we
are describing the
atoms, that they only
exchange one photon when they
go from one state to the next.
And this is a full description
but not the only description.
So therefore, we need
an intermediate state.
But assuming that the
first laser is not
resonant with the transition
to the intermediate state,
we need this dashed line.
This dashed line is sometimes
called a virtual state.
And in the following
discussion, we
will really learn what is the
nature of the virtual state
and what does it mean.
But we need a stepping stone
for a two-photon process
in the form of
intermediate states.
So maybe I should
just use three minutes
and show you how you
would calculate it.
I use pre-written
slides here, because I'm
getting a little bit
bored of just writing down
the same or similar
perturbative expressions.
And I just step you through.
So I said we use
the dipole operator.
But now-- and this
is a new thing--
the electric field
has not only one
component and one frequency.
We want to look at two
photons, so therefore, it
has two frequencies.
So therefore, our
perturbation Hamiltonian
is what we had so far
for monochromatic field.
But then we have
an additional term
where we just change the
index from one to two
to have the second
laser field described.
So let me now introduce
matrix elements.
We have to go from state a
to some intermediate state.
And then we go to state b.
So therefore, we
need matrix elements
which take us from
state a to state f.
And again, we have two
such possibilities--
one at omega 1,
one at omega 2, one
driven by field 1, the
other one driven by field 2.
And yeah, we all have
the counter-rotating and
co-rotating terms.
What happens is we have, of
course, a complex conjugate.
But I told you
already several times
that there is an e
to the minus i omega
1, which is responsible
for absorption.
The plus i omega
1 does emission.
And let me just-- I want
to do the rotating wave
approximation, only
keep the relevant term.
So I look at
two-photon absorption.
And that means I only keep
forward the minus terms.
You could, if you
want, duplicate
the lengths of each
formula and carry forward
the counter-rotating term.
You're not learning
anything new.
You get additional
Bloch-Siegerts
and AC stark shifts.
This is not the new feature
I want to implement.
So let's focus on
the new aspect.
And this is the following.
We do first-order
perturbation theory,
which takes us in the first
step to the intermediate state.
And you have seen this
expression many, many times.
The only thing is in addition to
what we had for one laser beam,
we have to add a second
possibility, which
comes from the second field.
And now we are at the
intermediate step.
And we want to take the second
step to the final state.
So what we are now doing is we
are writing down Schrodinger's
equation, derivative
of the wave function
is Hamiltonian times
the wave function.
And we are especially
interested in how
do we accumulate probability or
amplitude in the final state.
But what we are doing is
on the right-hand side,
because we can't start
in the ground state,
we've gone to the
intermediate state,
we are now plugging in
the previous result,
the first-order result for
the intermediate state.
So therefore, by using
second-order perturbation
theory, we want the second-order
perturbation theory,
so we integrate this equation
with respect to time.
But on the right side, we
use our first-order result,
which we had derived earlier.
And then we just write
down the integral.
Everything is just
exponential function.
And we get the result here.
So now with two steps, we
have obtained an expression
for-- I know time
is over, but let
me just finish the argument.
So we have now an expression
in second-order perturbation
theory.
What is the amplitude
in the final state?
And things look a
little bit messy,
because we have four terms.
And we should get
four terms, because we
have two interactions.
We can take one
photon of one laser
beam-- first step, omega
1; second step, omega two.
We can switch the
order of photons.
And of course, if you write
down everything correctly,
nothing is forbidding the atom
of taking both photons out
of the same laser beam.
Yeah, let me stop here.